sí
buen trabajo te deje con esta pregunta
porque hay exactamente 6 combinaciones
de cada reparto cuando estamos
seleccionando a tres actores de un grupo
de cuatro para tener una buena intuición
de qué es lo que está pasando veamos las
primeras dos cajas observa que en el
primer elenco o caja tenemos todos los
posibles arreglos de a b y c y los
matemáticos a cada uno de estos arreglos
le llaman una permutación
el número de permutaciones está
representado por el número de filas en
cada caja lo mismo es cierto para la
segunda caja que involucra a b y d y
cuántos arreglos o permutaciones hay de
tres cosas
anteriormente vimos que hay tres
factores o sea seis permutaciones listo
esa es la respuesta para evitar que el
orden importe tenemos que tomar el
número total de combinaciones donde el
orden sí importa y dividirlo entre el
número de posibles permutaciones cuando
escogemos a tres actores de un total de
cuatro actores podemos escribir nuestros
cálculos como 4 por 3 por 2 entre 3
factorial lo cual es igual a 4 hagamos
otro ejemplo y encontremos cuántos
repartos podemos hacer con tres actores
de un grupo de seis actores en este caso
tendríamos seis por cinco por cuatro y
después otra vez tenemos que dividir
entre tres factorial para evitar que
importe el orden
y eso nos queda como 6 por 5 por 4 entre
3 factoriales que es igual a 20 por lo
que hay 20 repartos diferentes en este
caso utilice el próximo ejercicio para
obtener un poco de práctica con otros
ejemplos y quizá reconozcas a nuestro
buen amigo mod en el reparto